President Trump campaigns in the Dakotas
today and it's a safe bet we're gonna
hear more attacks on the anonymous
member of an alleged resistance within
his administration president slammed the
person who wrote a New York Times
article during a rally in Montana last
night he called the author gutless and
said it was a threat to the country at
least 28 officials including the vice
president the first lady and members of
the cabinet have denied they wrote that
op-ed it's hardly the first search of a
for a high-profile anonymous official in
Washington a 1974 Wall Street Journal
article detailed the hunt for deep
throat the source who provided
information about the Watergate scandal
the paper wrote mark felt says he isn't
now nor has he ever been deep throat in
1974 felt told the journal I'm just not
that kind of person the former top FBI
official revealed he was deep throat in
2005 the USA TODAY's Washington bureau
chief Susan page joins us now good
morning Susan
hey good morning John so you think not
one but two possible constitutional
crises may be in the offing here why
what do you why's that well I think we
have this portrait from the New York
Times op-ed from the Bob Woodward book
and from just the daily news coverage of
this White House of a president who is
erratic who is mercurial who even his
own staff doesn't trust that raises
questions about his fitness for office
but you also have the picture of what
Bob Woodward calls an administrative
coup d'etat unelected unaccountable
officials countermanding undermining
some of the decisions made by the duly
elected president now which
constitutional crisis you worry about
more probably depends on what you think
about President Trump how do you run a
railroad when this is going on what does
this do to the process of if it's
already chaotic inside and there's been
a lot of reporting about that how does
this how do things change now you know I
don't think our railroad is running very
smoothly down a track at the moment we
have a town a capital that is pretty
much transfixed by controversies daily
controversies over the White House and
the president it's really an
extraordinary situation when you have
the Vice President and almost every
member of the cabinet
feeling compelled the issue denials that
they portrayed the president as of
someone who is unfit to serve that's
just extraordinary
and Susan listen I have a couple of
questions can you imagine any scenario
that anybody steps forward and says yep
it was me that's number one number two
how does a White House team function
when there's such a lack of trust
amongst itself how do you see that self
working how do you see that working the
White House staff has some loyalists to
the president trust but it is not in
fact a White House staff that works in
the traditional way of of earlier White
House's there is not a lot of trust and
I've got to say the events of just the
past couple days is likely to erode
whatever trust there has been on the
White House Stephanus particularly with
the president and his sense of faith
that those around him are not leaking
negative stories about him that's got to
be tough and Susan you know there's an
erosion of trust in our industry as well
as journalists a big debate as to
whether the New York Times should have
printed this anonymous op-ed at all how
soon do you expect that we will find out
who the author was and how much pressure
is on the New York Times to up the ante
and make sure that this really was a
high-level official so again this
depends on where you stand do people who
have trust in the New York Times I think
believe that they wouldn't have
described this person as a senior
administration official if he or she had
not been that but we've seen this great
erosion as you say in the news media and
one of the things that contributes to
the current state of turmoil across the
country is I think a lot of Americans
just don't know who to trust they don't
know who to believe when these
controversies come up meanwhile finally
Susan the president's nominee for the
Supreme Court seems to be going through
that process on his way to perhaps a
second successful result when you step
back and look at it despite the turmoil
the president and his party are getting
what they want and you know you may
worry about whether the government is
functional but whatever happens with
President Trump he could be impeached
tomorrow his impact on this nation is
going to be set in a big way assuming he
wins this second confirmation for the
Supreme Court and to the seat that has
been the swing vote all right Susan page
thank you very much always good to see
you thank you